et pour revenir sur les principales
annonces des manuels macron nous sommes
avec benjamin cauchy porte parole de
debout la france etc ce gilet jaune et
puis clément armato porte-parole de
l'uni l'union nationale inter
universitaire est également avec nous
messieurs bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
à voir clément armato je me tourne vers
vous en effet manuel ma croire annoncé
des mesures pour la jeunesse comme des
exonérations de charges pour les jeunes
diplômés ou la mise en place de trois
cent mille contrats d'insertion on
regarde et on en parle juste après nous
allons avoir un dispositif exceptionnel
d'exonération des charges pour les
jeunes en particulier pour les faibles
qualifications
il y aura trois cent mille projets
d'insertion pour les jeunes qui n'ont
pas trouvé d'entreprise
clément armato vous êtes satisfait par
ces annonces du président alors comme
dhabi comme d'habitude avec emmanuel
macron on n'attendait pas grand chose
mais on est quand même déçu
c'est cette annonce d'exonération des
charges est bien plus faible que celle
qui avait été défendue par les députés
il ya quelques jours et qui a été rejeté
par la majorité présidentielle
et on le voit cette exonération de
charges ne prend pas en compte les 710
le diplômé de l'enseignement supérieur
qui vont arriver sur le marché d'emploi
dès septembre de plus les trois cent
mille contrats aidés c'est un retour aux
emplois d'avenir la vieille recette
socialistes que quand il ya une crise et
donc créer des emplois d'avenir financés
par des impôts et par de la dette et
donc ce n'est pas ça qui crée des
emplois ce n'est pas ça qui relancent
l'économie et ce n'est pas ça qui va
créer une situation stable pour ces
jeunes benjamin cauchy vous comprenez
cette déception après ces annonces alors
que la jeunesse a été annoncé comme
étant prioritaire dans le plan de
relance économique des manuels macron
oui absolument on peut comprendre le
désappointement de du représentant de
l'une des meilleures syndicale est l'un
des meilleurs syndicat étudiant qui
puisse exister en france et guy
un dresser un constat parfaitement
lucide j'ai souvenir quand j'étais
étudiant qu'il y avait à l'époque les
emplois jeunes qu'il était finalement
une fausse bonne idée puisque pendant
près de cinq ans des gens ont travaillé
et non absolument pu n'ont absolument
pas plus pardon cotiser pour leur
retraite donc faire attention à ces faux
emplois qui ne résolvent pas le problème
en revanche moi j'attendais de la part
du président macro et bien qu'ils
proposent une année blanche sur un plan
fiscal et social pour l'ensemble des
entreprises françaises et je pense
notamment et j'ai vu votre reportage sur
les patrons de discothèques sur les
cafetiers sur les hôteliers qui sont en
train de souffrir grandement et qui sont
eux le générateur de véritables emplois
donc encore une fois emmanuel macron
bien sûr sa poudre de perlimpinpin mais
ne répond pas aux vrais problèmes
alors on vous a entendu à faire l'éloge
de l'union on peut le dire vous êtes
tous les deux
ancré à droite et pour certains le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron lui
aussi penché à droite le président s'en
est défendu on regarde le gouvernement
aujourd'hui constitué est un
gouvernement qui a des femmes et des
hommes qui viennent de la droite comme
de la gauche et à peu près autant d'un
côté comme de l'autre
alors pour vous qu'en est -il est ce que
le gouvernement macron penche à droite
ou par clément rama tôt alors non
clairement le gouvernement dacron comme
depuis le début de son côté la pente
hutteau à gauche on le voit sa majorité
présidentielle est composée d'anciens
socialistes
si on prend gabriela talent c'est un
ancien socialiste et c'est donc c'est
pas parce qu'on prend 2,3 personnes de
droite les droites
la preuve en est sarkozy a fait
l'ouverture à gauche ça ne pas
sanctionner ça n'a fait que tu es déçu
eh bien c'est exactement pareil pour
emmanuel macron doux à droite
nous ne soutenons pas ses ministres qui
vont faire le lèche bottes et la
république en marche alors un nouveau
chemin benjamin cauchy annoncée par le
président tout cas un nouveau chemin qui
part pas à droite non plus pour vous on
m'écoute et moi quand je prends un
chemin je préfère avoir un guide de
randonnée plutôt qu'un président de la
république qui est en train de nous
droit dans le ravin clairement pour moi
ce gouvernement qui n'est ni droite ni
de gauche il est europe et east et il a
su rassembler autour de lui des gens des
républicains comme darmanin comme
monsieur castex comme lé paquet de leurs
philippe comme monsieur le maire et
comme bien d'autres et puis la rue ni
effectivement des gens de gauche mais
leur point commun ces lettres d euros
pays c'est à dire qu'ils ont donné les
clés de la france à l'union européenne
est donc aujourd'hui le clivage pour moi
il est plus droite gauche aujourd'hui le
clivage il est entre ceux qui ont donné
les clés de la maison france à l'union
européenne et ceux qui veulent récupérer
ses clés pour sauver la france et
redevenir maître de son destin et
clément bateau est ce que les clés elles
ont été donné un petit peu à la jeunesse
aujourd'hui ou pas par le président
emmanuel macron avec les alors non pas
du tout aux cliniques les navettes ces
données à la jeunesse au contraire
emmanuel backrooms vous retire des clés
de plus en plus nous faire des portes
puisqu'il n'y a aucune réforme de fond
est structurelle depuis le début de son
quinquennat
ce ne sont que des mesurettes sont que
des petites réformettes
il n'y a aucun projet sur le long terme
on le voit au sein d'enseignement
supérieur nous avons été pendant cette
crise les grands oubliés de la crise
sanitaire et du confinement à cause
d'une ministre qui est inexistante
d'ailleurs il a eu un mot pour la
rentrée des classes
pas pour les facultés est-ce que vous
avez une vision pour la rentrée
prochaine
alors non nous n'avons aucune vision
pour la rentrée nous avons à l'heure
actuelle ministère qui est aux abonnés
absents depuis le début du confinement
il ne répond à aucune question il
navigue à vue il a totalement abandonné
tous les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur qui doit se débrouiller
on a une ministre qui il ya quelques
temps disait qu'il fallait faire du
distanciait la rentrée et qui hier vient
d'annoncer qu'il était cent pour cent
pour le présentiel donc en fait ils
naviguent totalement à vue les étudiants
sont très inquiet et on se dirige quand
même vers une situation c'est très
compliqué surtout quand on sait que nous
aurons cent mille bacheliers de plus à
la rentrée qu'il va falloir j'irai alors
inquiétudes des étudiants vous n'êtes
pas les seuls on a vu les manifestations
à cet après midi le président s'est
d'ailleurs et
ce prix met sur les comportements dans
les manifestations je vous pose de
regarder je crois que la haine n'est pas
acceptable en démocratie et la haine
dans le discours et la violence dans les
manifestations ne peuvent être acceptés
benjamin cauchy en tant qu'ex gilet
jaune
est-ce que vous rejoignez les propos du
président sur les violences dans les
manifestations
vous savez les violences m moi je
comprends que les français sont à bout
les français sont à bout parce que il
n'ya plus de 18 mois des gens de tout
horizon politique des gens de toutes
origines sociales de toutes classes
professionnelles s'était réuni dans la
rue pour demander plus de justice
sociale et plus de justice fiscale
juste avant cette crise du coc vide qui
évidemment rebat les cartes
aucune réponse n'a été apportée lerrick
n'a pas été mise en place
aucune réforme constitutionnelle pour
mettre en place une dose de
proportionnelle comme le propose debout
la france à hauteur de 25%
rien n'a été fait pour la baisse de la
tva sur les produits de première
nécessité donc on comprend qu'il ya une
colère latente et donc le fait que
emmanuel macron prétexte que la crise du
coc vide doit nous permettre de faire
des réformes qui sont bien comment
dirais-je conséquence de casse sociale
bien évidemment que je peux comprendre
la colère maintenant la colère ne
justifie en rien la violence que ce soit
la violence à la fois des black blocs
qui viennent salir les mouvements et les
manifestations d'aidés soignants
aujourd'hui mais que ce soit également
une attitude comme mirage du
gouvernement inadmissible et qui
manipulent les phases tort les forces de
l'ordre et qui demande aux forces de
l'ordre d'agir très rapidement avec des
gaz lacrymogènes c'est absolument
incroyable donc emmanuel macron à soi
disant changer de chemin d'une écoute et
c'est un chemin qui est pavée pavé de
gaz lacrymogènes clément armato sur ces
manifestations qui ont lieu encore cet
après midi dès gilet jaune mais aussi
des soignants votre réaction
on comprend la colère des français
on peut voir la même colère chez les
jeunes aussi il ya une colère qui monte
de plus en plus mais cela ne justifie en
rien les violences on le voit souvent
ces manifestations en fait sont
récupérés par l'extrême-gauche
l'extrême-gauche qu'on croise dans les
airs
cité est un gosse que le gouvernement
laisse prospérer et laisse s'entraîner
dans les universités aujourd'hui la
veille pour le metical est là c'est
qu'il ya une arrière base qui permet à
ces mouvements d'extrême gauche de
s'entraîner se préparer au combat alors
pour parer à toutes ces vielles à tous
ces violences le président a également
annoncé le port de caméras pour tous les
policiers lors de manifestations
regarder nous allons généraliser avant
la fin du quinquennat
les caméras piétons pour rétablir la
confiance entre la population et la
police
une bonne idée benjamin cauchy écouter
est ce que vous croyez sincèrement
qu'une caméra sur un policier va faire
que les gens qui vivent dans les
banlieues se vivent concrètement et
correctement
est ce que vous croyez que si des
policiers avaient mis des caméras sur
leur uniforme il hier il n'y aurait pas
eu de bus brûlé à nanterre est ce que
vous croyez que le chauffeur de bus à
bayonne n'aurait pas été assassinés est
ce que vous croyez qu'il eut admis
murray pas de d'horreur et de drames au
quotidien non sérieusement je pense
encore une fois que c'est du marketing
manuel macro et là ne sais faire que ça
de toute façon c'est de la communication
alors peut-être qu'il y a à l'exception
et à la marge et on le regrette
évidemment qu'on peut corriger des
policiers qui focalisait loup qui
exagèrent dans le traitement des
interpellations mais je crois que c est
caché c'est un arbre qui cache la forêt
d'une grande majorité de policiers qui
fait parfaitement son boulot
en revanche je préférais qu emmanuel
macron s'attelle aux racailles parce que
l'art à tahiti dans nos pays je crois
qu'il faut vraiment insister là dessus
alors autre question abordée par le chef
de l'état l'écologie un qui était au
coeur du nouveau chemin a voulu par le
président et à référendum le plus vite
possible sur l'inscription de l'écologie
dans la constitution
beaucoup de jeunes apportent cette
question de l'écologie
est ce que pour vous c'est un enjeu
majeur clément armato alors au niveau de
la jeunesse il faut bien prendre en
compte que les jeunes qu'on voit se
mobiliser ce sont toujours les mêmes
ce sont des jeunes qui sont ultra
politisé et généralement peu utilisé à
gauche à l'extrême gauche bien
évidemment le sujet l'écologie est un
sujet important pour l'avenir est
important chez les jeunes
mais ce n'est absolument pas le sujet
prioritaire aujourd'hui
jeunes ils veulent en parler ils veulent
trouver des solutions mais des frais
solution pas de la décroissance pas une
écologie punitive pas qu'on les empêche
de rouler compte de les empêche
d'utiliser en voiture qu'on les empêche
de prendre l'avion
non ils veulent une écologie humaine une
écologique intelligente un référendum le
plus vite possible sur l'inscription
l'écologie dans la constitution ça vous
semble important c'est une idée que vous
pourriez porter benjamin cauchy et en
tant que porte parole de debout la
france mais écouter s'il devait y avoir
un référendum avec une thématique
écologique je croise très demandés aux
français s'ils souhaitent
oui ou non que la france sorte des
traités de libre échange qui pour le
coup met des millions de containers tous
les ans de suivre sur les océans est qui
et qui fragilise à ce que les français
sont pour ou contre les éoliennes qui
tue la faune et qui abîme la fleur est
ce que vous croyez sincèrement que cette
convention citoyenne a servi à quelque
chose moi quand je vois les mesures qui
ont été prises par exemple qu'il faut
désarmer les véhicules de collection il
considère que les véhicules qu'ancien
sondés sont des armes qu'il convient de
désarmer voilà l'exemple et pour moi le
ridicule de cette convention citoyenne
donc quatre jours nous avait choses
concrètes à savoir à 20 ans les traités
libre-échange privilégions les circuits
courts et ça je ne pense pas que ça
nécessite du référendum et du courage
politique encore faut-il qu emmanuel
macron ondes
alors bien évidemment la crise sanitaire
également avec le port du masque
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
à partir du 1er août on en parle
beaucoup
le chef de l'état qui assure que tout
est prêt dans le cas d'une seconde vague
vous le croyez clément amato forcément
non le prends pas comment il a géré la
première sac
cette endémie ne peux pas croire que ce
sera après le promu deuxième c'est un
surcoût cool lui permettre à lui au
gouvernement de mieux se préparer à une
seconde vague de tirer les leçons
du confinement et les indicateurs
sont en train le petit peu de repasser
au rouge dans le voit plusieurs articles
parlent nombreux cas à marseille dans le
sud
et pourtant emmanuel macron on annonce
que le masque obligatoire à partir du
1er août soit dans quinze jours que
d'ici là la situation peut très
largement empirer donc on le voit il se
laisse il pense encore avoir le temps et
que ça pourra se gérer très rapidement
comme d'habitude ils pensent que c'est
la start-up teschen et qu'il suffit
d'appuyer sur un bouton
c'est vrai effectivement pourquoi dans
quinze jours benjamin cauchy ça aurait
pu être plus rapide selon vous cette
obligation de port de masques dans les
lieux publics clos
je pense qu'il doit y avoir une la seule
raison pour moi qui puisse être rentable
c'est le fait que le caractère
obligatoire du port du masque doit
nécessiter le fait de donner des masques
de façon gratuite à des gens qui n'en
n'ont pas les moyens et donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu emmanuel
macron n'avait absolument pas préparé
une deuxième vague n'avait absolument
pas prévu qu'il faille donner des
masques de façon d imposer le masque de
façon obligatoire dans l'ensemble du
pays
parce que si tel était le cas il aurait
déjà prévu les acheminements de masques
pour les personnes qui n'ont pas les
moyens de s'en acheter
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
s'il ya des gens les fans d' emmanuel
macron les électeurs du manuel macron
s'il en reste et veulent attendre le 1er
août et bien et bien leur en soi mais en
tout cas j'invite chaque français à
prendre sa responsabilité et dans
l'yonne dans les lieux clos la sncf
l'imposent déjà vous lorsque vous prenez
un train lorsque vous rentrez dans une
gare quand j'étais hier gare du nord on
impose de porter le masque
donc j'invite les français à ne pas
attendre énormément du d'emmanuel macro
mais de se prémunir de tout danger de
porter un masque si ils peuvent s'en
acheter évidemment en tout cas une
gestion d'une éventuelle seconde vague
une relance économique avec un nouveau
gouvernement
le chef de l'état on a également parlé
il a il s'est arrêté un sur le casting
du gouvernement notamment sur le cas de
gérald darmanin on le sait une
nomination à comprise notamment par les
féministes avec une affaire de viol un
qui suit de très près le
nice de l'intérieur emmanuel macron
défend je cite la présomption
d'innocence contre la démocratie
d'opinion ce sont ces mots vous
rejoignez cette vision benjamin cauchy 1
mais écoutez monsieur monsieur darmanin
et tu accuses mnm n'a pas encore
aujourd'hui de culpabilité sur le dos
pour autant je trouve que sur un plan
politique au delà du jugement il ya
quand même des symboles et c'est vrai
qu'il paraît plus que délicat d'avoir à
la tête du ministère de l'intérieur une
personne qui est suspecté de viol voilà
ce que je peux vous dire je ne dirais
pas plus la sphère est en cours il ya
déjà eu des non lieu de prononcer mais
c'est vrai que ça crée quand même un
certain malaise et lorsque emmanuel
macron revendique de mettre la cause des
femmes en haut de ses priorités
sacré quand même un malaise et on peut
se demander si des femmes battues des
femmes maltraitées
bon encore avoir le courage de franchir
les portes d'un commissariat lorsqu'il
ya des suspicions sur le premier flic de
france clément en bateau c'est le bon
casting ce gouvernement pour faire face
finalement une éventuelle seconde vague
on le disait pour enclencher le plan de
relance selon vous c'est surtout pour
l'instant un casting people un casting
qui permet de faire parler de ses
placements dans les médias la plupart
des ministres juste changé de
portefeuille et nice terre c'est vrai
c'est la même équipe au fond et
seulement un tiers du gouvernement a été
renouvelé c'est pas vraiment le
remaniement
alors pour conclure là après l'autre
interrogé à plusieurs reprises sur sa
volonté de se présenter pour un second
mandat
emmanuel macron a balayé je cite une
question à tempe et style à il a parlé
d'une vision à 10 ans pour autant est-ce
que vous avez aussi entendu le candidat
à la prochaine élection
clément armato oui bien évidemment ce
discours était un discours d'une
personne qui veut être candidate
mais bon ça serait mieux pour la france
et que les français qui se termine en
son mandat se termine en 2022 en 2022
faudra mettre fin à l'expérience macro
mist benjamin cauchy le mot de la fin
écoutez moi je me souviens que en 2015
françois hollande était encore
prédisposés être candidat en 2017 que
vous connaissez la suite de l'histoire
donc si manuel macron a des ambitions
présidentielles et bien tant mieux pour
lui en tout état de cause moi je peux
vous assurer que chez debout la france
on se prépare à ce que les républicains
les patriotes et tous ceux qui aiment la
france fasse barrage non seulement
emmanuel macron met à gagner et à faire
en sorte que l'on change enfin logiciels
et enfin de systèmes dans ce pays merci
à tous les jeunes d'avoir accepté notre
invitation benjamin cauchy je rappelle
que vous êtes porte parole de debout la
france écrit le gilet jaune à clément
armato merci à vous vous êtes
porte-parole de l'uni c'est l'union
nationale inter universitaire